The political discussions on this app are getting really unhinged.
Just normal. We're gearing up for an election.
It always gets kind of crazy,
especially on social media,
as we get closer to Election Day.
And this particular election,
I think, is probably more important and more hyped
and more controversial than any other that I've been alive for.
And I'm voting for Kamala.
As a person in a red state
with a daughter
who's gonna be going through puberty in the next four years,
it's. It's an easy choice for me,
and I understand why people aren't.
But I just wanna remind people of this phrase that is kind of
kept me focused and centered during all this,
and that is, think globally,
act locally. What's going on in the rest of the world is important,
but where we can enact change is right here at home.
Local elections, domestic elections.
I consider it a power that I have to stop the worst happening here,
so eventually we can hopefully stop the worst happening out.